>From here on out I'm going to
assume that you want to be a hedge
fund manager.
And one of your first tasks as a hedge
fund manager is to get investors.
So who might your investors be?
There are three major types
of investors in hedge funds.
Of course, there's others besides these,
but these are the three main types.
Individuals, in other words, a single
person that wants to invest in a fund.
Of course,
these are typically very wealthy folks.
Keep in mind that hedge funds typically
can only have up to 100 investors.
So they want each of those
investments to be fairly large so
that they can manage, of course,
a significant amount of funds.
So the individuals who invest in
hedge funds are typically, as I said,
very wealthy.
Institutions.
What do I mean by Institutions?
These are things like very
large retirement funds,
like CalPERS out in California.
These are university foundations like
the Harvard University Foundation or
the Georgia Tech Foundation.
In other words, institutions,
very often non-profit
institutions that have a large sum of
money that they need to keep somewhere.
And of course, they'd like to
see an accrual in value, so
that's one reason they
look to hedge funds.
And finally, funds of funds.
What funds of funds do is they
group together the funds of many
individuals or institutions.
So for instance, you might be
an individual that could, say,
invest in one hedge fund, but
you'd really like to get the advantage
of investing in several funds.
So you might allow your money
to be collected by a manager of
funds of funds.
And then that manager would gather
together all these assets and
pick carefully several hedge
funds to invest that money in.
So besides knowing who
your investors might be,
it's critically important to know
why they might invest in your fund.
How can you present the case
to them that will convince
them that they should let
you manage their money?
Here are at least some of
the criteria that folks like this
would consider before
investing in a hedge fund.
Track record.
So if your fund has a great
track record, that's, of course,
some of the best evidence that it's
going to continue to work well.
Many institutional investors will
want to see a good track record for
at least five years before they'll
invest in a particular fund.
Now if you're a young whippersnapper
hedge fund manager and
you don't have five years yet,
what are you going to do?
Well, what you can do is simulate or
back test your strategy, and
investors will consider
these simulations.
But that simulation has
to be backed by a very
compelling story
describing that strategy.
In other words, you've gotta have
a reason for why this method works and
it needs to make sense.
And finally, they consider how your
strategy fits within their portfolio.
In other words, if your strategy is for
large cap S&P 500 stocks, and they've
already got that covered with another
fund, they might not consider you.
However, if you, for instance,
are looking at small cap growth stocks,
and they don't yet have that
part of their portfolio filled,
they'll give you some more thought.